[Music]
good morning hey guys today we are on
our way to a martial arts training
workshop seminar what else can we call
this class what yeah yeah we have Isaac
in the back seat Bevan all right so you
want to talk about what kind of thing
we're heading to because I have no idea
I'm just tagging along to film it and to
keep the guys company here because I'm
not being involved in this hell yeah so
today we are going to Noah
he's a Taekwondo master no we've
actually worked with them a lot in the
path of JK films and stuff used to
choreograph a lot of her fight scenes
were skits and recently Jo has been
really interested in martial arts in
Taekwondo and just taking in general and
so he's been learning from Noah and
today Noah's holding a seminar for more
people to come join and just kind of
learn and that's was fun and I thought
it'd be awesome idea to bring Isaac
along because I've been wanting to take
Isaac into martial arts or dance classes
or just more extracurricular activities
and I thought well here's a seminar
where there's a lot of people whether
they're beginners or pros coming
together having fun helping each other
out and I thought oh what a great
environment to come into Anna knowledge
really patient and use a great teacher
selves like this is the perfect
opportunity to introduce Isaac to some
kicking and some punching and we'll see
how Isaac like this today excited baby
yeah you remember you actually have
worked with Noah a little bit so a
couple years back no one was doing this
video
something about Star Wars and something
about children involved I can't remember
but Isaac was going to be involved in
that video and I can't remember why he
couldn't do it I have a horrible memory
thing we were out of town a lot of times
Isaac gets casted in these things
whether it's Wong foo or with Noah or
other things and it just happens to be
there in the time and we're out of town
we travel a lot so it sorry oh sorry
Thank You Ben don't you could have a
complete actors demo reel by now Oh true
well you know it is okay because you've
been gaining experience in life with
traveling the world sure it's fun are
you looking forward to learning anything
about martial arts and
on a kick all right we made it it's like
a thousand degrees it's all huh
are you melting too very had I'm going
to cheer up my glasses because I don't
want to split any skirt falls off oh
yeah my glasses are falling off my nose
are how to cover your hair kid has been
hit what if you like it this is how hot
it is my glasses are slide right off my
knuckles that's it we're here are you
hugging sweaty at me seriously
hi are you gonna train with us we're
here at my seminar ready to go I'm like
super sweaty it's 104 outside on a
filing fee in here so I the healthiest
an year old now sounds good I know in my
head I have to say push them harder
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right you like so bad you're all get
out I can make you like I'm doing better
I'm the only one in excitement we were
all going to do it together
yeah you saying that to me like what
should we wear you were like excellent
gonna be wearing jeans until we get here
- the only one right all good ready to
be ugh I do it nicely
I'm actually very excited with my body
over here Jax will rush us i cuando
ellos it's do remember I so wanted a boy
come over this way actually do you got a
first bow my knees are here
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you could be a professional bow before
you going my little brother yeah don't
go yes I wanted to Wow guys can both
kicks together yeah you guys could be
partners did you want to train and take
that place or shy off pinning tiger
that's a big for me you feel like a
tiger you're nice and light either side
I like I don't know you I want you guys
to kick
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
do you like this do you like martial
arts
yeah this went wrong
you got kicked in the face before
[Music]
[Music]
it was awesome
super tired I really realize how much I
saw that's what this seminar did for me
it made me realize how much I suck at
this
the Graduate but once but it lands not
how good you are how much fun is
happening and how how much hearts put
into it so oh my bad I think I do
alright well home good and tired picking
up in the car yeah all four so we're on
a new schedule right now then we're
getting ready for a wedding usually on
the weekends you're at your dad's house
and on the weekday jur with us so
basically we're reversing that schedule
where Isaac is going to spend this
weekend with us and he's going to spend
the week days with his dad yeah because
I mean we're going to be keeping Isaac
for three weeks straight and so in those
three weeks is I'm going to get to see
his dad so we were like oh boy you're
just spend the week over there and make
up for that time so he gets to spend
time with his daddy and with us pretty
cool I really like the fact that all
three of us we co-parent really well we
found our chemistry is good so today is
Sunday now we are enjoying the second
day which Isaac read over here
hey babe yeah so right now we're heading
over to Cassie AKA
Blogilates studio and we're going to do
a workout so I got my workout here on
trying to get our wedding pods oh yeah
so she's going to help us out work us
out really hard even though she had a
really good workout yesterday with melih
as of right now as it's recording this
is like what like nine days so we blast
press about yet real much time I know I
haven't been very good about working out
at all prepping for the wedding at all I
just did you know Bart even created an
entire program for me with this Titan
program and so I've been really bad -
Bart I'm like I'm sorry I just I'm too
stressed out right now I can't go to the
gym even though I know going to the gym
is good for stress but I just like to
find excuses to not go work out Pacific
Gas but right now I have no excuse and
I've been tested convince you to work
out yeah so okay the other night on
Friday night we all went over to walk
throughs office they were having a party
and it was like the greatest time ever
it was really fun we got to see all of
our friends and Kathy was there she was
like I just heard them saying you're in
and I'm like I'm in for what you were
like Sunday we're working out I'm like
I'm in let's do it let's get wedding
ready
Isaac is wiped out from yesterday's
martial arts seminar so he's like I'm
not trying to join you guys at all baby
yes
my whole body's sore the first time I
actually did actual workout long never
felt this way before so you like to
weigh your body hurt after that I can
tell that you'll be active person so
there was and Olivia I always hated that
feeling I never ever ever learned to
love that piece I got to learn to love
it say about the door Prieta going to 10
seconds okay
as the first round people that I
remember taking any pain I didn't take
themself and there's like outside
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay oh my god how do you do this every
day of your life is terrible
Shetty to the wedding yes I literally
felt the world go black for a second yes
not good I was like okay I feel like
such a failure but I really have to say
hold on a second I saw my food coming up
now
I will never active ever like specific
you look so good I think I'm just really
lucky look but I think that arises thank
you for having that baby but I was
blinded by their own yeah let's go again
that's right oh charger for body filling
out my sore body smells horrible any
good workout yeah
did you are you like then join in
yeah and I really ah ah do it it was so
hard my wife down Turkey oh it was easy
huh so happy you said that
oh we had another hotel I am i
confiscated welcome to the party
no how do you do I couldn't keep up
today you kept up way more than I did I
always gave up like I think I did like
two or three of the motion taxes give us
yeah those sidekicks I was doing
yesterday with Noah done and then we had
today that today cash is giving us a
tour of her place all the time is so
cute everything that you designed them
like I love everything you're so much
like totally my pathetic and the
trashman's everything with our magazine
covers now we're gonna have lunch
lemonade lemon on all hand for well
I wish workout Foley and I also because
you're there oh I did it for the best
images on the workout okay the best
really good
Isaac ran away you can find away I do
want them it's really good right now so
I will try and solve it or monitored
yeah it was really cute talking about
how you for coming
we are on our way through the wedding
virgos to Paris we're going to get
married it's official rot away to the
wedding please man didn't Eddie happen
there you know it's weird the closer
closer we're getting the less and less
anxious and nervous and all that I'm
getting
[Music]
[Music]